Great. You're listening to radio man,
the podcast from New York public radio, public radio, w.
Y. C. N. N. P. R. Hello everyone. I'm Jad from Radiolab.
I'm here to tell you that we're getting very close to season four,
but before we get started, I wanted to just point you to something.
We have started a blog, a radio lab blog,
which will contain all kinds of stuff, ringtones, even extra interviews,
videos. I'll be posting some music, putting some cool articles.
Robert will be putting some posts on there, so if you need a fix,
if you're bored at work, there's interested in you know, cool ideas.
Check out radiolab.org click on blog now about to change your life just a little
bit. I'm going to play you one of my favorite pieces of all times for one of my
favorite producers of all time. Her name is Sharon Elise.
She's an Australian and she makes all of these pieces,
which are kind of in the same manner that radio labs sometimes does radio,
which sounds a little bit like music, but it's also like radio,
but it's like music. She's in that, in that spirit as well.
She will take speech and edit it into a musical little situation.
I don't want to say too much more about it except to say that it is called
simply if,
if [inaudible]
if is,
it's a lot of [inaudible] trying to help someone before flower finch
is all we're flying with the friend of the fish. If,
if I was a a bird
looking at the children that will really sick,
if, if
crocodile, if,
if our plants,
like if our kid teach kitty,
if, if, if,
if,
if I was, uh, a bird and I saw a vantage around someone's head,
I'd pretend it was my nest and start laying her eggs there
if [inaudible].
Oh, darn it. Well, he didn't. Huh?
[inaudible]
if I were finch nesting and in the children's hospital and I saw a caster or
around someone's leg, I'd think, is that the, um,
what Michael was saying, if Andrea in the beach scuttle fisheries it yet,
I think it was a Scott, a scuttle fish, and I'd start shoving my bacon on it.
Hello.
Sweet Woo. The coral fish inside of his fall.
[inaudible] in the children's hospital. I'd be thinking,
thinking, who's in the cage? Is it me or is it you? Well,
it's mainly fish.
When I first get there, they, why me, you know, take a blood test,
see how high and write it all down.
[inaudible] someone comes in and says, well this is what's up via this, this,
this, this and this.
[inaudible]
my, it was low calcium
this, this, this, this and this.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
if are a kid,
it'll like if our plan at the children's hospital and I saw the kids go past,
I think to myself,
I'm lucky the plants seeing all these sick kids go by and I'm as fetus fiddle or
I might be turned into a fiddle that I'll be fit as a fiddle.
And just the other week I had a biopsy. They, they,
they put you to sleep and then everything goes,
I'll find you when you are in a sleep a, it just goes to see if it's a, um,
a lollipop. You know those big ones, how they roll
[inaudible]
no.
It's like when you get a pencil and your pain rate in certain places,
the those spiral kind of like, and when you roll it,
it goes all funny
brown.
Yeah.
That that sort of felt like everything was going round and round and round and
round and land. I wake up and then I go to
bed feeling money fro who's a funny,
if he's, Oh our frog in the children's hospital,
I'd be stuck in someone's fright because they swallowed me.
Now they got a frog in their throat.
If I was a good yes,
he's good in a children's hospital, drawing a picture,
I draw a cat and say, Ooh, I [inaudible].
I draw a polytech.
Yep. Yep.
I always ruin a good picture. I add things on tickles. Nice.
Now keep adding and adding and adding and adding. Yet when I finish,
I think I've got too many things. See like this.
I drew a doggy flat and then I decided to do a bed and then I described as as a
pillar and I decided to do the nurse.
Then I just started to do his hands.
Then I decided to do little by little shadow within day.
No wonder the sheets, the dog, he,
he's spewing up [inaudible].
[inaudible].
Yes, like the drawings and the art.
They made me get better because once I did them, I thought, oh,
this is a not picture. And then insight made me feel a little,
you know, that fuzzy feeling yet.
Woo, Woo, Woo, Woo, Woo.
It's our TT, right?
If our kid sleeping on a bed,
that's if by Australian producers share to lease to find out more about shared
Elise, check out our new blog. We have links there.
That's radiolab.org click blog. And you know what? If that's,
if that story didn't make sense,
if you're sitting here like what does listened to it again,
trust me the second time you hear it, it'll make perfect sense in any case.
That is it for this week.
Radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
Thanks for listening and stay tuned. Next podcast for season four.
I'm Jad Abumrad.